I think that one thing that can be so
life-changing is a commitment to a
weekly live show are you gonna mess up
on your live stream yep are you gonna
start and want to deliver a great
opening and stumble over your words
absolutely the advice today especially
with these five tips is start your show
and start going live
welcome back to the think media podcast
I'm super fired up for this episode
because we're talking all about live
streaming now we love live streaming on
YouTube We love multi-streaming and
today I've got Gage from stream yard
breaking down five tips to help you get
more views more reach and some tactical
tips to improve your live streams and
make sure to stick around until the end
of the video and podcast because Gage is
also going to be breaking down a new
feature that's coming to stream yard and
I don't want to over hype it but I am so
excited for this feature I'm going to
tactically be sharing we were talking uh
before the recording about what it is
and I'm already like this is exactly how
we're going to use it at think media so
if you're ready to get more subscribers
get more views tap into live streaming
or boost your streams then um stick
around because it's going to be a power
packed episode but Gage welcome to the
show hey Sean thanks so much for having
me on I'm super excited to uh to be here
excited for you to be here as well um
you're the co-founder and CEO of stream
yard a lot of people should know about
stream yard by now but if you're new to
the platform what's kind of been the
history and vision of the company
yeah absolutely uh time has has flown by
but yeah about three years ago Dan my
co-founder and I um we set out to we
wanted to make the easiest way to create
professional uh live streams we thought
they were really really good Solutions
out there for folks that were pretty
technical but three years ago there
really weren't very many solutions for
uh people that like there were people
that had great content to share and
really good ideas but might not have
been interested in things like bit rates
and encoding and and setting up this
software so we wanted to make something
that really got out of the way and
allowed people to focus on what was
important uh being their their content
um so that was sort of the start of the
the journey and both of us Dan and I are
both Engineers by by background so kind
of had to teach ourselves a bit about
marketing and growth and it was cool to
have live stream as a way to help grow
our our product that um I think we'll
talk a little bit more about it later
but we've actually done a show uh for
the whole three years uh it's a town
hall we do to get insights from
customers and and help grow our our
following
um but yeah that show's been great
because it's given us feedback to
iterate and continue improving the
product to give the best experience
possible and yeah at the end like you
mentioned really excited to talk about
that because we're starting to Branch
into not just being the easiest way to
create professional live streams but the
easiest way to create professional
content in general because I think
there's a ton of folks out there that
need a solution not just for live
streaming but for all kinds of content
creation
yeah I love that and this new feature is
going to really be a game changer I'm
convinced of that but one of my favorite
words is the easiest you know even as a
tech guy myself
um live streaming stressful because if
you're thinking about the tech you're
thinking about you want to share a
screen you want to power it up with
banners or details all this different
stuff you got enough to think about just
trying to deliver your content or
interview your guest and so that's
really why we've fallen in love with
stream yard at think media because of
ease of use speed of implementation ease
of setting it up of course a lot of
practical features like being able to
multi-stream
um but uh it's an incredible product and
it's cool to see it continue to evolve
but let's dive into these five tips and
then we'll get to that announcement but
first one is increase viewer retention
by sharing your screen or using multiple
cameras how can why are our live streams
more powerful when we don't just talk on
screen but we maybe share a screen or
switch up our camera angles and how are
creators doing that
yeah absolutely so as I'm sure you know
better than anyone else like one of the
most important signals you can give to
to platforms like Facebook live or
YouTube live is how long people are
watching for because if people are
watching for a long time it's going to
tell Facebook YouTube hey this is good
content and we should show it to to more
people which is going to be really
important for continuing to to grow your
channel
um and that's not to say that if you're
just on screen by yourself that you
can't be entertaining
um and there are people that are very
successful doing that but one easy sort
of uh additional way you can go about it
if you aren't comfortable just being on
screen all by yourself is to use
functionality like sharing your screen
in multiple cameras because it gives
something uh else to uh to to for your
audience to focus on and and be
entertained by it's a much easier to
speak to maybe a slide deck or a
presentation uh that that you're
presenting versus just you on screen uh
having to move your hands around and and
and keep people excited about what
you're you're talking about
um so I think that uh utilizing that
functionality of the different Studio
options in stream yard like the the
multiple cameras like sharing your
screen is really important for getting
people to watch
um
getting people to watch longer
um one that like like I mentioned before
in terms of making stream yard easy this
was one of the things that
um we were fascinated by in the overall
industry that made us think that stream
yard would be an important solution to
have is I don't know how familiar folks
are with sort of the history of
different live streaming platforms but
one of the uh one of the most successful
ones that actually stuck around there's
been tons that have come and died was
actually twitch and I think one of the
things that actually made twitch
successful is people were able to defer
the entertainment to the game that they
were playing it was much easier for
people to be entertained and watch a
watch a broadcaster if they had a game
that could sort of offload the
entertainment versus
um you know if you remember meerkat or
Periscope or it's just you on screen
having to be entertaining the whole time
so with stream yard we wanted to
replicate that so even if you're not
into video games being able to use the
screen sharing functionality or camera
angles or banners or comments to help
make it easier to make an entertaining
live streaming and keep people watching
longer
yeah it's a powerful tip and of course
average view duration and audience
retention is everything on YouTube and
and I think there's a principle to even
say in editing that you want to change
the scene every seven seconds I've heard
every five seconds that's quite often
but if you could imagine a comments on
screen or a camera angle changes or your
slide goes uh a screen share is brought
on screen and one of the things that I
use constantly is I am always doing
slide decks or not always but a lot of
times I'm teaching from slide decks it
allows me to also kind of hide behind
them kind of as you mentioned it makes
the content richer so I'm just not out
there by myself but I might be can look
at my notes bring the slides Up full
screen but I love how stream yard also
has like different levels where I can
make the slides a little bit smaller
make myself larger and in my mind using
just the user interface I am just kind
of trying to make a change ever so often
can I change this the scene I mean even
as we do this video podcast
I can you know pop myself up full screen
I'm managing the entire if you're on
YouTube watching it
um I'm managing this by myself very
easily in the back end which again gives
you just a visual switch of course later
on that multiple camera angles the cool
thing is there is a learning curve for
sure but I've never seen a software that
makes it more easy than stream yard to
switch that up and the impact is
absolutely massive but let's talk about
number two streaming to multiple
destinations why is it from your
perspective that your creators and users
love to not just stream one place but to
tap into the power of multi-streaming
yeah absolutely and I'll be super
curious to hear your perspective on it
because I do think multi-streaming is a
is a complex subject in terms of when it
makes sense and when it doesn't make
sense so I think when it's appropriate
it's a very very powerful tool and the
whole idea with stream yard was to make
it seamless and not having to be
fiddling a lot or fiddling around with
getting you know your rtmp keys and
things with different platforms and
figuring out how to actually set that up
string art just makes it a few clicks to
connect those destinations and and go
live to them
um but I think the power of
multi-streaming really depends on your
goals so if you're um if you consider
yourself to be a YouTuber and your main
goal is growing your YouTube channel I
wouldn't always recommend
multi-streaming because in that sense
YouTube is kind of like your product
YouTube is what you're trying to to
build and in some ways you kind of want
to be driving traffic to YouTube if
that's the main thing you're trying to
trying to grow if if you're a business
owner like like myself you know
obviously stream yards a business and
we're trying to grow that business you
want to reach your audience wherever
they want to watch from and that's where
multi streaming becomes really really
powerful like our our goal was to grow
stream yard as a business and grow our
community and that's where I thought
multi-suring made a ton of sense because
it wasn't so much about growing one
particular Channel or one particular
audience it was about growing all of
them and allowing people to have the
easiest feeling experience
yeah from my perspective I love it and
we do ask the question right before
doing a live stream Where should this
stream is it relevant to go multiple
places I'm also further along in my
Creator Journey meaning we have a team
now and we have built up other social
media platforms over time I would agree
with the sentiment that if YouTube's
your main focus and I would argue that
for many it should be their main focus
because you don't want to spread
yourself too thin why are you also
trying to grow on Instagram or twitch or
somewhere else and Facebook but in our
case like we want to deliver YouTube
tips
um effectively in multiple places and
for a lot listening to this you may have
a Facebook page for example or a
Facebook group what are you doing there
and and one of the things that I always
talk to the think media team about I'm
like what is the worst that can happen
if we also stream it to like my Facebook
fan page which is Sean Cannell and they
sometimes might say well the engagement
or organic reach over there isn't very
good only 32 people watch and I was like
why would that be bad I mean that was 32
people that wouldn't have been watching
otherwise and in some cases uh are how
effective it is can be even Superior to
that so typically uh the biggest use
case for me personally is
um I'll break down two strategies one is
we do have the coffee with candles show
and that's a live stream q a show and
what's cool about stream yard is it
pulls in questions from both places too
so as a solo manager of the stream I'm
able to answer questions I do a little
bit of teaching and I'll typically
multi-stream to YouTube our podcast
Channel and then I'll multi-stream to uh
Facebook my Facebook page and then I
might throw it to our think Media Group
which a lot of people don't know about
it's one of those like
kind of like lesser nurtured platforms
but again there are people there from
different things we've done in the past
so that's like and it's so easy I'll
check the three boxes upload you know
dial in the title dial in the
description any kind of Link or call to
action upload the thumbnail schedule the
stream and then start it all very easy
the second cool thing that we do is we
will sometimes
um start the Stream
on like YouTube and in a private group
and give if you will free content or the
free stream that's just publicly
available but we'll cut it on the back
end not something I do personally
because I'm kind of focusing on the
content but uh we might have someone on
the team like Kyle just say okay and
I'll I'll end it I'll say so hey thanks
for checking out this video you know if
you um from here on out stay on if
you're a part of it's a it's a sunset
program now but we had a program called
Inner Circle and then we would continue
in a Facebook group after sharing the
first part publicly so I think I share
all that just because there's ways to I
think think outside of the box and
there's also ways where this might not
be relevant today as your brand evolves
if you're listening to this as your
business evolves as maybe the products
or programs are exclusive or premium
content that you create evolves there's
different ways to tap into the power of
multi-streaming I mean that's a couple
the ways that we do it at think media
number three is up the value of your
streams with videos overlays music and
visuals
um tell us a little bit about that and
what some of the things you're seeing
that not just stream yard offers but
maybe some of your favorite live streams
from creators in your community
yeah absolutely so I think I would
bucket all of those things videos
overlays music and visuals into just
branding overall like how people are
branding and packaging uh their their
live streams which I think is really
really important I think obviously uh
nothing's more important than the
content itself but how you package the
content is is essentially part of the
content too and it can really help make
your make your broadcast more memorable
and help people know what to expect from
you each time you you go live like for
example some of the most successful
people I see on stream yard the content
is not necessarily drastically different
but the person's perspective on that
content is really what makes them stand
out from the crowd and help them Foster
a really strong Nation a strong
Community
um around that that content and part of
creating that perspective and creating
that brand and people knowing uh who you
are and and resonating with with how you
think is using things like videos
overlays music to to to create that
memorable uh variants and some of the
best ones I've seen they'll often open
with like an intro video they'll they'll
maybe have some subtle background music
while they actually do their their their
show and of course they'll have
different visual assets uh they'll show
throughout the throughout the the stream
at various times
yeah one of my favorite things is
um for example coffee with candles show
it has this countdown that goes three
two one and then it's we I encourage
people to make intros short you don't
need a 10 minute you know yeah intro but
it's a cool branded intro a lot of
um creators I know will sometimes use
countdowns as a way to ramp up and allow
people to jump on their stream before
they jump on camera that's very cool but
the other thing that I love is that you
can upload videos to play
or you can play videos off your hard
drive and that can be really powerful
for a couple reasons
one react is a format of content on
YouTube so if you want to play through a
video pause it react to it you certainly
also could pull up a screen share as we
mentioned in number one click the little
box in stream yard that allows you to
share audio and react to other YouTube
videos or new segments or different
things that's kind of a whole genre on
YouTube but I also think about the
opportunity to
um you could download those videos or of
course be playing your own assets on
your own hard drive that you're reacting
to playing or speaking through the
reason I love having videos is we create
our own ad spots and of course not just
because we want to build our brand but
by an ad spot I just mean like my book
YouTube secret second edition is out so
we go 30 seconds it's maybe me it's
pre-recorded it's edited together and
I'm like I'll be back in just a second I
hit the the
brand video play that thing it also
gives me 30 seconds to take a sip of
water to you know kind of get refreshed
remember where I am because once you hit
live man it's non-stop it's like if
you're gonna do an hour-long live stream
it's a marathon like you're doing it
some people are going multi-hours so if
you have videos and you plan ahead yes
they could be promotional what could you
promote but they also when someone might
say I don't have anything to promote
well what if you made a video that was
just educating people about what they
could expect from you on Instagram how
to connect with your community deeper
and so you might not necessarily have
something to sell like a book but you
could just say
um do you want to connect deeper
um on Instagram you know I do my stories
over there and just think about things
you could promote to enroll your
audience more and not just turn those
into videos that you upload to stream
yard or play off your hard drive but
also just as a way to give you a break
enrich your live streams let you
recapture your energy reset the view
viewers attention there's so many
different ways you can use videos I like
overlays too if I'm going to teach five
points I pre-upload the points and put
them on screen of course you can change
up your background and your banners
music all of these things enhance it and
it all comes back to average view
duration like how can we keep the viewer
watching longer and all these little
spices kind of spice up the live stream
recipe to make people uh want to stick
around longer one of the other things
you mentioned on this one though is that
you can do record only videos to reduce
editing on the back end uh break that
down a little bit
uh yeah absolutely so if uh if there's a
segment of your live stream uh that you
have prepared beforehand and that you
you know you don't want to necessarily
do on the Fly uh you can you can
absolutely uh prepare all of that
beforehand on on using stream yard or
whatever programs you want and upload
that before the actual uh before the
actual uh broadcast so that you can have
a long segment during the stream that's
actually pre-recorded we see lots of
events leveraging uh this this this
feature if there's maybe a speaker that
couldn't make it there live but wanted
to record their segment beforehand uh
they can upload that uh the other aspect
of this that sometimes people use is
making the entire stream pre-recorded
sort of like a simulated live stream
um personally not a I'm not the biggest
fan of it because I think it's if you're
doing a live stream it's generally
better uh for it to actually be live and
to build that trust and and uh and for
people to know that hey you're actually
showing up right now for for them that
being said there are times where
Evergreen content makes a lot of sense
for things like webinars I think the
doing a full pre-recorded stream can
work really well and we've actually done
that a little bit for for stream yards
own uh webinars we do an unlisted
YouTube essentially and for certain
types that uh that that happen all the
time we do actually use a pre-recorded
uh stream and just play that we do have
people hanging out in the chat so people
know it's pre-recorded and we answer
questions so at least it still feels
um pretty engaging and and like not like
we're just like set and forgetting it um
but I do think that's a cool feature for
for webinars this right there is a huge
unlock and if you're listening lean in
for this because
um this shows you an asset you could do
this in two different levels of
complexity level one would be okay if
I'm gonna do the coffee with candle show
and it's an hour long I could do an
interview with somebody that's maybe
quick and they break down a segment with
somebody that's going to break down some
new YouTube news in my case a quick
interview with somebody else and let's
say that thing is then just pre-recorded
and saved to the hard drive or then
uploaded to stream yard mid-stream to
your point you're enhancing something
with pre-recorded content and you don't
need any fancy editing to do it you may
throw up a banner during that time you
may use stream yard to just all in one
it's not live it's saved now and it's
something you insert in a future live
stream it's absolutely brilliant and
then of course you could also take that
file and spice it up a little bit to
once again add enrich your content and
for some they also think okay if I'm
gonna do an interview show I need to
synchronize my calendar I've got I work
weird hour I'm trying to build up my
side hustle again I think about one of
my favorite channels is Michael Zuber
one rental at a time and in real estate
investing and one of the things he
actually doesn't live stream that much
what he does is he brings on Experts and
he shoots three videos with them at a
time and they're anywhere from like
eight to sixteen minutes no editing and
he's like hey we're gonna talk about CPI
the Consumer Price Index right now we're
going to talk about the Seattle housing
market right now and then that expert
just delivers value for like seven eight
nine minutes and then he just uploads
that well you could have segments and if
you're like oh I'll be so complex to
bring on three experts in my Niche you
could have seven minute interviews with
three different people play those and
narrate those through once you I think
that the the key here is understanding
what tools are at your disposal when you
start understanding your tools getting
kind of different strategies and
different Frameworks you can make
basically hybrid shows you're having
this great live show you're bringing in
pre-recorded content you're sharing your
screen you've got a surprise guest that
nobody knows about but they don't have
to be waiting in the background the
whole time you just got a five minute
interview with maybe a business owner
owner or a leader and then and you could
say I can't wait I have a surprise guest
today they don't have to be there live
but it's still actually has that
experience and uh so many different uh
level UPS more spices to make your live
stream even stronger and so um number
four though engage with your audience
and so what are some of the ways that
stream yard gives us to engage with our
audience
yeah one of the most popular features we
have that we talked a little bit about
uh before is the ability to bring
comments directly into the the studio so
whether you're going just live on one
channel or you're going live on Facebook
um
Facebook Twitter Youtube all at the same
time all of those comments will come
directly into the studio so one great
way to engage folks is to actually show
their comments on screen and acknowledge
them to let you know that uh to let them
know that you care and actually call
them out specifically and answer their
their questions uh Banners are also a
really popular feature for that for sort
of also organizing your overall content
but also popping it up on screen and
letting people know what you're going to
talk about next and it does go back to
sort of the initial point we talked
about in terms of giving YouTube and
Facebook signals that hey this is good
content that people care about comments
are part of that if people are
commenting engaging with it that's going
to tell Facebook and YouTube hey we
should consider showing this to to more
people so it's uh it's definitely
helpful uh definitely helpful for for
for that and increasing that engagement
I do think depending on your overall
show format and sort of show strategy
different aspects of it can make sense
because one thing you do have to
consider if you're doing a podcast or
something
stopping in the middle of a podcast to
answer questions all of the time might
not make for great podcast content so
you do have to consider what actually
makes sense for for your show uh so for
podcast oftentimes what I'll say that I
think is really great for building a
community is it's they treat it more of
like a live recording where they'll do
lots of q a at the start to get people
excited they'll do maybe you know the 30
minutes for an hour or an hour of
actually recording the podcast while
it's live streaming and at the end
they'll go back to q a so they don't
really sacrifice the the podcast itself
or or the portions that they might might
not might want to repurpose uh but they
still get that engagement before and
after the stream is over very
intelligent it's a very good Nuance on
how you can kind of do both hand
um knowing what's going to be maybe
evergreen or repurposed or reused and
maybe front loading with q a it's
interesting as we are figuring out this
journey of the think media podcast I
think we're almost to a million
downloads on audio I think we crossed
2.5 million views on YouTube two totally
different things overlap but kind of two
totally different things and one of the
things we're considering is that our
video podcasts are really not the same
thing like that that we may be trimming
more things out of our video podcast
audio is sort of different the attention
span there people are doing chores
they're working out they're listening to
the whole thing YouTube you need to get
straight into it all of those nuances
saying that though you know we could
certainly do a live recording of a think
media podcast that is front loaded with
questions and it has all kinds of other
features but maybe the core content is
chopped out and then what ends up being
published to we use Buzz Sprout and then
it goes out to you know uh apple and
everywhere else you know uh Spotify all
the above well that's just that middle
as you described and so you've you've
you just know that you plan ahead of
time and you can ultimately use that I
also love what you mentioned about
asking questions we use the banner
feature oftentimes to pre-type and
pre-prepare a question which one of my
favorite live streaming tips
think about your live stream ahead
almost like the power of visual
visualization it's like closing your
eyes opening up a run of show even if
that's just a Google doc and like
imagining in your mind everything that's
gonna happen and then pre-loading that
because if you pre-load your points if
you pre-load a question you want to ask
if you pre-load a video you want to play
if you pre-load those things that's of
course a huge key so you're not on the
Fly wondering where you're going to go
next not unlike
you know I have a background in Ministry
in church so it's like we would have an
order of service you want to kind of
have a run of show even if it's in your
mind but even better if it's printed so
therefore you may at a moment just hit
your stream yard banner and your
questions ready to go what's nice about
that too is people jump on and off live
streams so they may pop on and just be
able to read what they should be you
know telling you in the comments your
question is like do you have a question
about
new YouTube features posted in the
comments you leave that up for 10
minutes questions are being attracted
even though you have to keep repeating
repeating yourself and then to that end
one of the other things I love is that I
am because of the power of stream yard
I'm able to do solo shows and I study
the comments through my dashboard and
what I tell people to do is put four
question marks before and after their
question so it really stands out as a
question and I use the star feature and
the star feature is nice because maybe
you're answering a question or you're
going through a whole segment and
questions are coming in you can just
stack them up and then interchange
between just the main comments tab
that's the aggregation right of Facebook
and whatever other platforms YouTube
You're streaming to but you got your
star Tab and then you can just
methodically go through those put those
up on screen I just did that this
morning in one of our YouTube groups and
so um amazing absolutely engaging uh
your audience with comments but also so
even pre-planning questions and be able
to throw those up on screen we will also
do that during a countdown so when we're
doing like a live web class we have a 10
minute countdown going we pop up a
banner that says where are you watching
from and it starts to stimulate
conversation as the stream begins and so
using banners like that too questions
are a social media hack period questions
do great nothing else just a text
question on your YouTube Community tab
you're going to be stunned by how many
people reply questions on Facebook
questions and Twitter people want to
answer questions you want more
engagement ask more questions and your
live streams and then social media
overall all right we have number five in
just a second we're also going to be
talking about a new YouTube feature and
breaking down all kinds or a new stream
yard feature and breaking down some
tactics related to that as I can already
imagine the 15 ways I'm excited to use
it but before we get to that new feature
um one if you haven't tried out stream
yard you can go to streamwiththink.com
again highly recommended yes stream
yard's been a sponsor and happily so
like we've been so grateful to be able
to work with stream yard because we only
want to talk about products that we know
love personally use and would recommend
to friends and family and stream yard is
a staple in think media it's just we use
it in so many ways publicly and
internally for our different groups and
communities and the speed of
implementation with which we can get
great content out there all of the above
the quality and ease of use the ability
to multi-stream a lot of the tips we've
been talking about in this very podcast
it's worth checking out so head to
streamwiththink.com
and you could also check out that link
in the show notes but number five is be
consistent
what have you learned about not just
going live once not just trying a stream
one time
and then being like it didn't work but
the necessity of consistency what have
you learned about that Gage yeah
absolutely it's something that
personally I've I've learned a ton of
myself it's something that I've observed
from other users uh the importance of
consistency but there's that uh that
saying that I really like I think it
goes something like oh it only took me
five years to be an overnight success I
think that's true to the maximum when it
comes to live streaming and anything
worthwhile anything worthwhile is going
to take time to to get results uh so for
example in my personal experience I
think we're almost at episode 200 of our
town hall for stream ride which is our
own live stream that we do to engage
with our community and answer questions
about the product and and get feedback
and when that started out obviously you
know there was probably I think we had
three or four people watching that was
probably my mom and a friend and maybe
one other person
um and now today you know string guard
as a product has millions of people
using it in that town hall uh has
several hundred people watching it uh
every single single week that are super
fans they're some of the greatest people
ever that really help us get the word
out about stream yard and if we would
have done our first couple live streams
or just looked at short-term results
over the first couple months like hey we
only Grew From five people to 15 people
watching uh we would have given up and
we wouldn't have be having the good
results we have today so
um it's a I think streaming and and
content creation anything is an
iterative process and you can't learn
and you can't get better if you don't
actually do it and you don't actually do
it consistently
as I think you will probably hear from
any uh any any high level or any
successful Creator I think would have
similar advice on the subject that you
have to keep going be consistent in
order to to get results
that's amazing you know my friend David
Shands says consistency is the only
cheat code
and I couldn't agree more consistency is
crucial and when you start live
streaming listen friends are you gonna
mess up on your live stream yep are you
going to start and want to deliver a
great opening and stumble over your
words absolutely are you going to
accidentally you know press the wrong
button or or sometimes maybe have
technical difficulties of course
um it's all a learning curve and the
cool thing though is that as you stay
consistent one viewers have Grace and
two at the beginning like you said it's
just your mom and like two friends so it
takes time to build momentum anyways but
what gets really interesting as and by
the way congratulate congratulations on
the 200th Town Hall that's consistency I
mean 200 different live streams and I
want some practical advice as we get
ready to talk about this next feature is
just this commitment to a weekly live
show I think that one thing that can be
so life life-changing is a commitment to
a weekly live show I think what makes
people afraid too is they're like do I
have to do this forever truth is listen
if you if you fall off a little bit or
you go into a season where you don't do
it it's not as big a deal as you think I
think what's more powerful is that for
the majority of time or for a marathon
run you do it and I remember back in
during the beginning of c19 and in the
middle of
um around March 2020 our reaction to
people kind of being in fear and panic
and shutting down and not sharing what's
going to happen and all my travel
getting canceled was to start a show and
I started a show also because I knew the
tool I had was that this was going to be
easy I could do this consistently this
was the simple workflow making sure I
set it up in a simple way simple promise
I started the coffee with candle show
shortly thereafter Heather Torres
started the YouTube Made Simple show and
I got a confession to make though Gage
is I have not done a coffee with candle
recently I probably haven't done it in a
couple of weeks still a show I still
come back to it but I probably went on a
100 episode run and it's still a show
that I can pop back into and I've been
traveling I've also got a 42 day old boy
at the time of recording and a
two-year-old so so we're fine like think
media is okay and there's probably some
demand and hopefully some Hunger for the
show but the cool thing is I can get
back to it I could pick it bad up back
up I think it's much more about progress
not Perfection but the commitment was
start a show just like you did stream
yard Town Hall you started show you hit
episode 200. question for you have you
ever missed a week
uh we actually haven't ever missed uh
wait one of us so there's been weeks
where I couldn't make it or Dan couldn't
make it but the show the show has always
gone uh live but I totally agree with
you that you shouldn't be discouraged if
you can't make a particular episode it
was just something that we decided like
that if we're gonna tell people to
consist be consistent we're gonna live
it and that's why we never missed a show
but you shouldn't be discouraged if you
happened the show must go on and that's
the second hack is if you have a co-host
uh and you have somebody else then if
you can't make it they can make it but
respect that means the week between
Christmas and New Year's you do the show
oh yeah yeah that means come hell or
high water you are doing the town hall
massive respect so whether you're
absolutely no matter what disciplined to
take it from episode 200 to 2000 of the
stream yard Town Hall show or you just
again progress over Perfection the
advice today especially with these five
tips is start your show and start going
live but we got a lot more to cover
because Gage not only is stream yard the
easiest platform to live stream but
there's a brand new feature called
perfect recordings coming soon explain
what this is and why it matters
yeah absolutely I'm so excited about uh
perfect recording so like like I
mentioned at the beginning the original
goal for Dan and I was to be the easiest
way to create professional live streams
but over the last couple years we've
seen more and more folks using screen
yard not just to do live streams but to
do recordings in general where they'll
hit that record only option just to
create a podcast or some kind of of
recording and stream yard is a good
solution for that but it's not the
perfect solution until now with this
perfect recordings uh feature and part
of the reason why we're so excited about
it is our part of our goal is to make
livestream is accessible as possible but
there's only so far we can go because
folks are still at the mercy of their
internet connection right like if you
live in the country or if you have a
slow speed connection and you can't
really you don't really have access to
upgrade that connection you're kind of
limited in in your ability to to live
stream so the really cool thing about
perfect recordings is even if you have a
bad connection no matter where you live
on any connection in the world you
should still be able to create very high
quality recordings and the reason why
that's possible is
because while the quote-unquote live
stream is going on you don't actually
have to be live we're going to be
recording another copy of that directly
on your computer which means you're not
at the mercy of the internet connection
even if you're having a conversation in
your podcast and the person looks super
super blurry or they sound like a bit of
a robot because the connection is bad
there's going to be a perfect copy
happening in the background that's going
to be uploading and that you're going to
be able to have access to so even if the
live recording wasn't great you're going
to be able to repurpose that content and
make something that looks truly
professional like you actually flew them
out into your studio to uh to do that
podcast so I'm really excited about the
use cases that it will hopefully unlock
yeah that's amazing and
um I'm very excited about this future
feature for one is because of the
opportunity for repurposing content you
know speaking of the coffee with candle
show as soon as you share this feature
with me I was about to fall out of my
chair because I love the ease of use and
the speed of use of stream yard it goes
Live on YouTube so if you're listening
to this picture and if you've ever seen
an episode you know I'm full screen I
put up some banners I play my intro
eventually I maybe share a few slides I
put some questions on screen whatever
and that all is one long file on YouTube
but one of the things we've been doing
lately at think media is repurposing a
lot of our content especially for
vertical video and for other YouTube
videos so I might go do a 90 minute
coffee with candle but there's moments
in it that is a good five minutes that's
worth chopping out editing up a little
bit better there's a 15 minute segment
that we could use in another way or
there's the Opera opportunity of tapping
into YouTube shorts tick tocks reels
Facebook reels and vertical video and so
having a perfect recording is a game
changer because of course stream yards
bit rate even depends on people's
internet connections and different
things like that so you've got this
perfect recording that you could Dropbox
to someone but you also said it's not
you're making it easy to even share that
file right yeah absolutely so depending
on the quality of the internet
connection of the person you're you're
interviewing or your own connection
we're going to be uploading that perfect
recording in the background so if you
have a great connection you're going to
have that live stream going on or that
live real-time conversation but by the
end of it you're that that recording is
going to be already good to go there's
nothing to upload or download because
that was happening in the the background
but it does also take into account if
someone is one of those people that's
you know blurry or or maybe they're
sounding slightly robotic uh that's
going to be happening at a much slower
Pace or maybe just waiting until the
stream is actually over for that upload
to happen to make sure that you know
that we don't degrade the quality of
what's Happening real time but yeah
after it's over if you do a show with
three or four folks that'll all be
stored in the cloud right on stream yard
you'll have access to those perfect
individual video and audio tracks and
sharing them out is as simple as as
sharing a link
um to to other participants beautiful so
it really bypasses Dropbox or Google
Drive you've got those files there you
could do a live stream but then you have
those for repurposing later or a re-edit
later or you could just purely use it
for the perfect recording feature and
then
um edit that together however you would
like later so it's a very exciting
feature and I think it just it just
further solidifies the market dominance
of stream yard because uh it's such a
multi it's like a multi-tool you know
it's a Swiss army knife of
um live streaming and now really podcast
recording video podcast recording and so
I'm super excited and pumped about that
um if you go to streamwiththink.com and
you haven't already jumped into
tri-stream yard you got to try it I mean
you could get a 14-day trial there and
highly recommend you you dive in and and
again I would say this if you're serious
about live streaming you're serious
about
building your business in the Creator
economy and you're serious about now you
know podcasting and video podcasting
which is one of the most
the number one strategies we teach Omar
has a whole series on it we think
everybody should have a video podcast at
some point in their Journey uh YouTube
as a side note if you go to youtube.com
forward slash podcast they hired an
executive for podcast a 65-page document
was leaked about their plans for
podcasting and so getting positioned now
to be thinking about having a video
podcast keyword by having you know and
tapping into a tool like perfect
recordings in the Stream yard is a big
deal and thinking about how you could
ultimately use that feature and start
getting ready ready now to create
world-class video podcast Gage I
appreciate you I appreciate your vision
for creating a tool that is so
thoughtful
um for creators that
um that you listen like you listen to
what creators want and I'm just grateful
for how intuitive and and forward
thinking
um that stream yard is because we need
we not only love it but I also love that
we don't feel stuck in yesterday but
that you guys continue to make updates
you continue to bring world-class
features to just stay on The Cutting
Edge of the actual things that creators
need so I appreciate you any final call
to actions where should people follow
you how can they find the town hall any
other things they need to know about
absolutely and thanks so much for for
having me on the easiest place is just
dreamyard.com you'll be able to find
everything on on streamyard.com and
thanks to you as well uh one of the
biggest things uh that gives people hang
ups is actually going live and feeling
confident about about going live and
companies like think media and your
channels really help facilitate that so
thanks to you as well appreciate you
thanks again
[Music]